buen día estamos hablando de 200 mil
votos que podrían marcar la diferencia
en el conteo final la estrategia de
keiko fujimori y sus asesores legales es
reducir los votos de pedro castillo y
conforme a esto la oficina nacional de
procesos electorales la declara
triunfadora de estos comicios el jurado
nacional de elecciones tiene tres días
para resolver este caso la sentencia
puede ser apelada mientras tanto este
pedido de nulidad de keiko fujimori le
impide a la oficina nacional de procesos
electorales declarar a un vencedor de
estos comicios
ahora porque con casi el 100% de las
actas escrutadas no se conoce un
resultado final hasta el momento cuando
puede esperarse entonces el anuncio
oficial por parte de las autoridades
electorales
bueno en realidad el proceso de la
oficina nacional de procesos electorales
está avanzando para ellos es rápido pero
para los peruanos y para la comunidad
internacional es lento a que se debe
estar lentitud porque tienen que
contabilizar los votos que vienen del
extranjero y en mayor proporción lo que
retrasa más es los votos que vienen del
interior del perú especialmente en las
zonas rurales hay las zonas que son este
muy agrestes de difícil acceso también
el clima tiene una implicancia en el
traslado de los votos y toda vez que se
presenten recursos de nulidad y también
impugnaciones esto retrasan más el
contenido de votos y en este caso este
pedido de nulidad de keiko fujimori que
interviene en otras las autoridades
electorales pone a paso más lento esta
situación hablando con algunos
entendidos expertos en esta materia
electoral peruana me señalan que esto
puede demorar unos cinco a diez días más
en el mejor de los casos porque tiene
pendiente también una apelación que
pueda
el grupo de pedro castillo francisco
gracias por información por supuesto muy
pendientes a lo que ocurre en perú en
torno a estas elecciones presidenciales